the latest data show another rise in
covid figures from the office for
national statistics show just under 2.3
million people were estimated to have
the disease in the week to june the 24th
that's a rise of just over half a
million or 32 percent suggesting the
surge is picking up speed the previous
week the increase was just 23
but looking back on the year so far and
the numbers are still below the peaks of
january and april the rise is being
driven by the ba 4 and ba 5 versions of
omicron which are taking over from ba2
the one that caused the april peak
they're even more infectious though for
the most part they're causing relatively
mild symptoms
so what's happening in hospitals then
well admissions are rising though much
of that is likely to be because people
are coming in for treatment of other
medical conditions and testing positive
at the door in other words the stats
reflect increasing rates of covet in the
community
but this is the worry the number of
older patients being admitted to
intensive care is rising the admission
rate bounces around a lot sharply up in
those between 75 and 84 here in red but
down in the over 85s in brown but there
is a general upward trend why now well
only 76 percent of people over 75 have
so far come forward for the second
booster dose offered in the spring so
almost a quarter of the most vulnerable
people are likely to be at risk from
waning immunity just as coveted rates
are taking off again
countries like france germany and italy
are also seeing a surge in cases but the
experience of portugal offers some hope
their cases peaked in june well below
the january wave of omicron and they're
now coming down
but the omicron family of variants seems
to be hanging around and vaccine
companies are urging health authorities
to make a speedy decision on whether to
update the jab in time for the autumn
booster campaign